all right I'm I'm not going to talk
about this every day but there is
something very interesting happening
with this forthcoming CNN town hall with
Donald Trump yesterday I told you that
CNN has announced they will be holding a
town hall with failed former and wannabe
future president Donald Trump and I
express concerns that they're treating
him like he's a normal person they're
treating him like he's just yet another
presidential candidate not a guy who
incited a riotous Insurrection not a guy
who's been indicted and arrested once
and potentially will be again
now getting another 24 hours of uh time
for CNN to promote this event
they're really pretending like he is a
normal candidate here is a promo from
yesterday morning on CNN including uh
the thoughts of Caitlyn Collins who will
be the host or anchor of that
forthcoming Town Hall so a quick
programming notice
is going to take questions from New
Hampshire primary voters
see it in town hall I'm in a modern
tournament next Wednesday May 10th at
9pm Eastern so looking forward to seeing
that uh really important for me to take
voter questions he is the front runner
right now in the GOP new overnight Sam
yeah so listen he's the GOP front runner
it's that simple it's going to be
interesting to hear a man sir oh how
will you keep in the undocumented
immigrants out this is not looking
particularly good it looks like this is
becoming 2016 part two the normalization
of absolute extremism our Argentinian
friend who's been a guest on the program
expert on fascism Federico Finkelstein
tweeted quote this is how the
normalization of wannabe fascist
populism happens and then here is a
little promo on CNN for the event former
president Donald Trump takes questions
live from CNN's Caitlyn Collins and New
Hampshire GOP Primary voters their
issues their concerns their votes a CNN
Republican Presidential Town Hall there
you go so so like I said yesterday I
totally understand why CNN is doing this
it couldn't be better timed you've got
millions of people furious with Fox News
because of they they fired Tucker and
these different things they've gone woke
um they settled the Dominion lawsuit and
they're looking for somewhere to go and
maybe that somewhere is going to be CNN
now as I said before I'm not opposed on
principle to having an event with Trump
but it must be handled correctly and
responsibly and it can't just be hey New
Hampshire voters ask about what Trump's
going to do about woke and trans you
have to make it clear
that this is a dishonest
paranoid
narcissistic conspiracy theorist with
things in his recent past that have
never been seen from the American
presidency and that none of this is
normal can Caitlyn Collins do that sure
will she do it I don't know my plan is
to cover the town hall live I know
people will say but David aren't you
doing the same thing CNN is doing no
this is a media analysis show and an
American politics show and one of the
things we do is look at how Corporate
media covers something like Trump uh and
we're going to be doing it responsibly
and if they uh rehabilitate His Image
and if they don't do the things that
they should be doing we will call it out
so my hope is to cover that live we
might get shut down by CNN as you know
that's happened to us in the past with
these exclusive events but that'll be
next week we'll take a quick break much
more to talk about today first